[BIRDS CHIRPING]
[TRAIN ON TRACKS]
People are feeling romantic
about nationalisation
because they don't
remember how awful it was.
The railway is a
natural monopoly.
You don't get to choose
which train you travel on,
which company you choose.
It doesn't make sense
to introduce a market
into the railway.
There are two big problems with
the railways at the moment,
the fares are too
high, and they've
been going up relentlessly.
And the second problem
I can put in two words.
Southern Rail.
If you look at some of the
trains they've invested in,
they're pretty unpleasant.
No tables.
Nowhere to put your drinks down.
It looks like the
sort of place they
want to hose down after the
passengers have been in there.
I think privatisation has
brought many advances.
Certainly one of
the advances brought
is an enormous increase in the
number of people using trains.
Jeremy Corbyn is a
great trainspotter.
So he and I see completely
eye to eye on the railways.
And I'd love to be
his thin controller.
[LAUGHTER]
We didn't feel it
appropriate to say
that the Chancellor and
the Transport Secretary
were locked in mortal combat.
But that is more or
less what it was.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Britain is the birthplace
of the modern railway.
But the network is now at the
centre of a political battle.
25 years ago every train,
every piece of track,
and every station in the UK was
sold off to private companies.
Now, with calls for
re-nationalisation growing
louder, we're here to ask, why
did we privatise the railways?
And was it worth it?
One man who was
there in the engine
room of the great
Conservative sell off,
stoking the fires
of privatisation,
is now better known as a
connoisseur of the railways.
Trains were old.
They were very often dirty.
And the most famous symbol
was the curly British Rail
sandwich, because the standard
of catering was so poor.
So it was universally
acknowledged
that the nationalised
industries were
giving an extremely poor
standard of service,
because they had no
accountability to the customer.
The private railway companies
were taken into public
ownership in 1948, when Clement
Attlee's Labour government
decided to nationalise
swathes of British industry.
By the time John Major became
prime minister in 1990,
the service was seen as a
neglected part of the transport
system.
Ministers thought British
Rail's management was asleep
at the wheel, and looked at ways
to bring in the private sector.
So why did the
rail privatisation
come quite so late?
I think it's partly
because it was complex.
And partly because I don't think
Margaret Thatcher particularly
wanted to do it.
I mean, it's odd,
because privatisation
is much associated with Margaret
Thatcher, and rightly so.
Although she moved into
it a little reluctantly.
She was quite slow to do
the first privatisations.
And railways and the
post office, for example,
were way down her list.
So it only got going
in the Major years.
And even then, it
took a very long time.
When I was first working on
privatisation, the plans we had
were not at all the plans
that turned out to be.
Quite honestly, the
principal motivation
was that we had an
industry that we thought
was in terminal decline.
And something, almost anything,
had to be done about it.
And this is really what I would
ask you to judge privatisation
against.
I know there have been
many other changes.
But not many people
gave railways
a hope, even of survival
in the late 1980s.
The railways more than survived.
But the journey has
not been smooth.
Awarding contracts at
the lowest possible cost
has depressed the quality
of train services.
The companies complain of
squeezed profit margins.
But passengers still seem
to blame the operators,
as the government piles more of
the costs onto the travelling
public.
As passenger fares have
risen, so has public anger.
And the remedy that
these angry commuters
seem to be reaching for is
to take the whole system back
into public ownership.
One commuter decided
he'd had enough.
David Boyle challenged
Southern Rail's poor service
by organising a protest
at Brighton Station
with his fellow passengers.
They were irate at the delays
and cancellations resulting
from an ongoing dispute
between the train operating
company and the trade unions.
They refused to
show their tickets
and had a tea party instead.
Well, the reason I got so
cross was during the strike,
when no one was taking
responsibility for it,
was it felt like you were
going into a restaurant.
They won't give you
your meal properly.
They're late in delivering it.
And they still
expect you to pay.
And what's more, they
check your ticket.
They have the nerve
to check your ticket.
So it seemed to me,
what would Gandhi
do in those circumstances?
He would refuse to
show his ticket.
It's a ripoff for both
passengers and the public.
And it has failed.
That's why we need
public ownership.
Cat Hobbs speaks for We
Own It, a pressure group
campaigning for public
services to be brought back
into government hands.
76% of us believe the railways
should be in public ownership.
And that's across
all age groups.
We know that people really
believe the railways should
be publicly owned.
And we can achieve
that very easily
by bringing rail
franchises in house
as they come up for renewal.
When you see the ridiculous
chaos in Southern Railways,
and the huge inconvenience
to the travelling public,
going back several
months, well, of course,
the public are entitled not just
to be annoyed, but to be very,
very angry.
If I used Southern
Railway, I'd be
livid at the nonsense
that's gone on there.
Another angry protester?
Actually, this is Malcolm
Rifkind, former transport
secretary, and one of the
architects of Britain's
privatised railways.
I basically reversed
what was perceived
to be a conservative policy
of the previous 12 years,
and said, I am unashamedly
part of a government
that is committed to an
expansion of the rail network.
And I had John Major's
full support in doing that.
When you were secretary
of state for transport,
you were not in agreement
with the Treasury
on how it should be done.
Yes.
Although I had no problem with
the principle of privatisation,
where I did depart from
the view of the Chancellor
of the Exchequer
and of the Treasury
was as to the separation
of responsibility
for the infrastructure,
for the railway track,
from the operating of the
railways that use that track.
To divorce from the person
who's running the railway
the ability to manage
the track as well
in the most economic
and sensible way
was irrational, bad economics,
and bad business sense.
Instead of pushing British
Rail into the private sector
as a single company,
it was broken
into three components,
track, rolling stock,
and train operators.
The real competition
on the railways
was not from other railways.
It was from whether people
decided to use the rail,
or to use air or
road in order to get
to where they wished to go.
And that meant that by the time
of the 1992 general election,
when the manifesto
was being drawn up,
we had not yet reached
a position on this.
This set out in here
is the sort of Britain
I am going to see, and
lead this country to
in the next few months.
In 1992, a secret
memo was circulated
among senior
conservatives discussing
how to privatise the railways.
The preferred option was
to approach privatisation
on the basis of line of route.
Why?
Because this was
easy to explain,
and was appealing to
local regional pride,
and a sense of identity.
The memo acknowledges
that this method would not
be the most
pro-competitive solution.
Opinion polls showed
that privatising BR
was popular with the public.
It would be important to
bring about privatisation
in a way that captured
the political trick.
If it meant you were
adopting a system that,
in all other respects,
was an inferior one, then
that would be a very
bad thing to do.
If you devise a policy
which not only appears
to be the best way of
running the country,
but happens in addition
to be quite popular,
yes, we plead guilty
as politicians
to being attracted to that as
a way of resolving whatever
the problem might be.
But now it seems that the
pendulum of public support has
swung completely in the
other direction and favours
the Labour solution.
I think the public mood is
there, absolutely there, saying
bring our railways back
into public ownership.
Clearly, in your view,
it would be a mistake
to follow the Jeremy Corbyn,
John McDonnell prescription.
I think it would be one of the
silliest, most foolish things
they could do.
Apart from anything
else, it would cost
billions of public expenditure.
There would be massive
disruption for a number
of years, until you got back.
And where would you
be going back to?
You'd be going back
to a state system
of running the railways,
which during the period that
had operated in this country saw
a constant decline in railway
usage and a constant increase
in public dissatisfaction
right up till the 1990s
when we privatised.
So that's what you call dumb.
There's no question
that passenger numbers
have gone up since the
railways were privatised.
The number of journeys has
increased from 761 million
in 1995 to 1.7 billion in 2016.
But most of this is
concentrated around London.
Not everyone thinks
this is fair.
I'm Lilian Greenwood.
I'm the Labour MP
for Nottingham South.
And I chair the Commons
Transport Select Committee.
We're here on this
train, speeding
north to your constituency
in Nottingham.
And clearly, there's an
enormous amount of investment
that has gone into
the railway system.
I mean, you could
almost say, the railways
have never had it so good.
There's a lot more
public money going in now
than there was at
the time when we
had British Rail as a
nationalised rail industry.
I think that's one
of the things that
perhaps is a concern about
franchising on its own terms.
It was meant to lead to
cheaper fares, a more
efficient railway, requiring
less taxpayer subsidy.
And actually, those things
haven't been delivered.
So how much money
does the UK government
spend subsidising each
of the train companies?
Well, it depends.
Between 2016 and
2017 all of them
received more funds than they
contributed to the government,
with two notable exceptions,
Virgin Trains East
Coast and South West Trains.
South West Trains
lost its franchise.
And Virgin Trains East Coast
has been flirting with collapse.
We ended up taking a
system and throwing it
into the air with
the infrastructure
pushed off into Railtrack
a privatised infrastructure
company, losing lots of the
engineering and expertise.
We have the train operations put
into 25 different franchises,
many more than there are now.
And, of course,
the rolling stock
sold off to the rolling
stock operators.
So it basically broke
our rail industry up.
I think essentially Railtrack
failed to properly maintain
the railway.
So routine maintenance
wasn't being
done, which led to a
succession of fatal crashes.
And it was the failure
of a privatised operator
to keep the network
properly maintained
and to keep people safe that
was an absolute disaster.
I mean, now we have the
safest railway in Europe.
That's something to be proud of.
But they had to come back into
the public sector for that
to happen.
Some veterans of the Labour
government in the 2000s who
re-nationalised Rail Track to
create Network Rail now believe
that creating more state backed
bodies could be the answer.
There should be
competition for franchises
between public and
private companies.
After all, we have state
companies in France, Germany,
the Netherlands,
and other countries
who can compete
for contracts here.
What we don't have is domestic
state companies, or not
for profit companies
that can compete.
There's a lot of
nonsense spoken.
Since all of the track and
most of the investment that
goes into the network
is public investment,
we don't have a fully
privatised railway in any event.
Over the last decade,
the private sector
has invested hundreds
of millions of pounds
into the railways each year.
But the amounts
invested by government
can be measured in
billions yearly.
It's not true capitalism, is it?
It's not a true market,
or true competition.
It is, to some extent,
pretend capitalism,
because the railway
operators are always
going to receive subsidy.
So is the supplier of the
track and the infrastructure.
But that isn't the
end of the story.
Because you can have
different franchise seekers
competing with each
other to see whether they
can offer a good standard of
service for a lesser subsidy.
It's a kind of negative
auction, in other words.
They are bidding for
the lowest subsidy.
Sometimes it goes wrong.
But on the whole, it
has not gone wrong.
And those who underperform
can be replaced.
Will be replaced.
Have been replaced at the
end of the franchises.
The reason why there's such
support for nationalisation
is because a lot of private
companies are doing very badly.
They're either not running the
trains, like Southern Rail,
or they're having to be bailed
out at taxpayer expense.
Like the East Coast.
You cannot justify privatisation
unless the private sector does
a good job.
I mean, I suppose people
do have short memories.
I suppose I'm in a
privileged position,
because I was in a
privileged position
to remember how bad things were.
Maybe it's the case
that we have to go
through the whole wretched cycle
again and learn the lesson once
more.
This nostalgia for
nationalised industries
is absolutely misplaced.
Perhaps people ought to go
and dig out their old Super 8
movies and try to recall
for themselves what
life was really like.
I'm doing nothing but wasting
my time the whole of the time
I've been on the train.
Two hours this morning.
I never get home till after
half past seven at night.
It didn't arrive down here
until three quarters of an hour
late, which means
we miss our buses,
and we don't arrive home until
about an hour and a quarter
later than we normally do.
Whatever the
solution, there have
been some punch ups between
commuters and railway staff.
Tempers have flared
on both sides.
And one loco man was
attacked with an umbrella.
There used to be political
energy around the idea
of privatisation.
We conservatives are
returning power to the people.
In the Thatcher and
then the Major era,
privatisation was meant to give
power back to the consumer.
But now, perhaps, it means
returning to state control.
Let the next Labour government
transform Britain by genuinely
putting power in the
hands of the people.
Power to the people.
Power in the hands
of the people.
[MUSIC PLAYING]